let me welcome you to this this workshop
session I'm very pleased to see so many
people particularly given the topic that
we're going to be looking at which is
partnered relationships
unfortunately my partner Andy Shaka
can't be here she injured her knee some
time back and she's not cleared to fly
so she couldn't get over here if it was
you know some warehouse and they could
have driven that would have been a
possibility so she wanted me to convey
to you that she's very disappointed in
not being able to make stoical on but
that she's found lessons from stoicism
very helpful in our relationship and
also in her relationship with with other
people and we're a couple who worked
together and then we live in a fairly
small apartment
we're both entrepreneurs among other
things and so we're on top of each other
literally all the time and so stoicism
has come in very helpful for both of us
she also finds it's it's helpful for her
and Graeme her business and in managing
some chronic health problems as well but
we're not going to talk to so much about
that but there could be something that
that plays a role in partnered
relationships so when they started
having a call for for those of us who
are involved with the modern stoicism
organization to do workshops and said
well what kind of workshop would you
like to do Andy and I thought you know
something on those those things that we
deal with it might be helpful for other
people and so we decided for sure go
ahead we decided to cause the stoical
hurt there's a perception quite often
that stoicism is unemotional or
unattached you'll see as you look at
some of the quotes on that document that
that's definitely
not the case so there's a lot of
questions that get raised how many of
you I should ask participate in any of
the online forum just like the stoicism
Facebook group there's like thousands of
members stoicism reddit
there's always questions about
relationships coming down I've just
broken up with someone so how do I
handle that I want to meet somebody who
will you know be compatible with me and
trying to change my life through
stoicism what should I do
there's an awful lot of that so I
thought that could be a good topic to
hit on and when we're talking about
partnered relationships so this is
fairly inclusive in scope it includes
what we might call depending on why you
want to frame romantic or erotic
relationships you know it's the very
first quote that I have for you there
has to do with erotic you know the
erotic and stoicism but it could also
include discussions about love or
attraction or companionship it's good
for those who have a relationship and
want to do better with it it's also I
think useful for those who are seeking
relationships and we might also even
talk about when it's good to end a
relationship when it's time to pull the
preferably a band-aid off all at once so
what I what I was going to do with this
you have a sort of overview of the
workshop itself we're going to go
through each of these topics you notice
that the first thing we're going to talk
about has to do with desires and ideas
and assumptions that we we 10 share and
then I'll give you some for those who
don't know about these some classic
stoic perspectives on relationships
primarily on marriage and we'll talk
about some limitations of that
we can adapt that to our much more vast
set of modern problems and and
relationships that we have and then I've
done a number of stoic practices laid
out for you that these are just five
that I think could be useful so you know
I'm good at dealing with any sort of
going off topic and coming back if you
have questions we can certainly answer
them at any point I did reserve about 15
minutes at the end for doing more Q&A
and discussion so if we if we have a lot
of discussion in the middle we'll just
take that off of the end but hopefully
we'll get through all of this material
so before we actually like jump into
what the Stoics themselves thought let's
talk about what it is that people and us
in particular do in fact desire from
relationships and we can frame this in
terms of desire and aversion what is it
that we we want what is it that you want
in a relationship with a point of having
one there's multiple answers so what are
some of the things that people want yeah
yeah I mean I something do have to
struggle to get people to bring that up
that's especially but spending and I
teach that college students as well and
the freshmen boy it's very very
difficult to get them to admit that we
have sexual desires and then we get
pleasure out of sex but that that's one
of the main points and having many types
of relationships what else
yep that's probably the second biggest
one and that often goes on long after
sexual desires wane what else for being
honest
yeah that can that can bring those those
all together what else that's a wonder
what are some of the biggest things that
couples actually fight about one is sex
right finances are just as important
while still we want yeah so now we're
starting to stray into the virtues right
yeah children you have to produce
children the Stoics were very keen on on
that yes somebody to Lena and notice
that some of these things you can get in
other places right you can have a friend
who's who's a support there could be a
companion there's nothing that says that
you relationship in order to have sex
right industries that cater to that sort
of thing what are we at first what don't
we want in relationships disharmony
hassles what else don't I see okay yeah
yeah only about about themselves or or
even worse if they care more about
something else than they do about
themselves were you that's particularly
galling
being stuck yeah that then happens quite
often in relationships go on and on so
what sort of people are we looking for
we could put some of these qualities I'm
looking for somebody who fits these
particular you know usually they talk
about needs these days nobody really
should call them desires or things that
were averse to what do we expect of
ourselves what we're thinking about
relationships what does a relationship
suppose to do to us there's there's a
lot of romantic stuff floating around in
there in our culture think about
rom-coms you know a relationship is
gonna make me no longer be a slob who
doesn't get much done and dresses poorly
or things like that I mean we have these
things sometimes and these are crazy
ideas quite frankly you know the notion
that somehow being in a relationship is
going to transform your life what are
what are some things that we really do
want about ourselves yes I guess to be
to be oh that's that's an interesting
yeah you know do you have a a right sort
of to be loved whoever you are we often
talk this way but you read ancient
philosophers and like well you're not
going to get loved unless you actually
are lovable and so if you've got a lot
of traits that are not only unattractive
but push people away and don't be
surprised when they don't like you you
know it seems fairly yeah
challenged uncomfortable that's true
when I think back over not just my
relationship with the Andy but other
previous relationships that that was
something that I certainly enjoyed
getting to see yourself through
another's eyes view is perhaps not too
bad right yeah yeah that's what was
that's what we're striving towards and
so stoicism we often think of it in
terms of individual wealth perspective
but for the ancients stomachs for most
people they thought of being in
relationships as central to what it
means to be yourself there's a lot of
talking about you know retreat to the
inner Citadel and and that's all true
but part of living in accordance with
nature means partnering at some points
or another for most people so I wanted
to give you a range of stuff from
classic stoic perspectives on partnered
relationships and there's a number of
things that that could be said about
that I've got several pieces in stoicism
today that I wrote back a while that one
for Valentine's Day this last year that
give a lot of you know where to look for
these things we know that the ancients
Stoics actually wrote texts that we no
longer have that discussed love and
friendship and erotic relationships and
all that sort of stuff
we know that Zeno wrote a Republic in
which there was something like free love
going on we're not quite sure what was
going on because most of the references
to it are fairly polemical but we do
have some things that the Stoics who we
do have said about so I wanted to hit
out a few of
one other thing before we look at these
if you if you think about it in terms of
goods and Bad's and then that whole
range of indifference much of what goes
on in relationships really has to do
with that range of preferred to rejected
indifference it's not necessarily things
that are good in themselves or bad in
themselves there's plenty of room for
the virtues to come in but the Stoics
thought that understanding and managing
these indifference properly was
absolutely an essential to the good life
this is nothing different from say the
cynics the cynics said you know you get
good virtue you got bad fights
everything in between forget it there's
also another guy Aris toe who is a
student as you know who broke off and
said something quite similar good man
and different and different doesn't
matter at all you can do whatever you
like with it the classic stoic strums
you know all the way on set know that
range of the indifference is extremely
important you just don't want to get too
invested in that you you know you can't
actually be wise if you're not managing
a difference well you can't be just
stoic sense without managing those well
so another thing that's that's really
important that ties in with that is this
notion of what's in accordance with
nature then I'd like to say too there's
some glosses on it that will say things
like well that just means following
reason or following the facts or
something like that
it's much more complicated than that in
accordance with nature is a great catch
phrase by when you read through the
classic stoic literature means a number
of different things and I give you you
know some of the things that are
connected to that these quotes but
there's like literally hundreds of
passages spent on it on explaining it so
how do we live in accordance with with
nature we have to think about our
desires
our perceptions and priorities and how
we realize these things and for the
classic Stoics partnered relationships
in the terms of the paradigms that we'll
talk about in just a minute so they were
part of how we would live in accordance
with nature we can do it in many other
ways to write you can preserve your
prior ASIS your a ruling faculty or
faculty noise in accordance with nature
when you go off to the baths which we
don't generally do these days but you
can go to the public pool I think about
all the hassles you're going to have
that's that's one way to do it but you
can you can't do it also in the
relationships that you have so that's
going to be central and the Stoics they
tended to look at a couple different
paradigms you notice there's quotes here
about the whys right the sage is often
how it's translated the wise person the
person who has cultivated the virtues
who's living the stoic life from almost
fully and notice when arias tells us
about the wise person wise person acts
improbably this isn't a list of other
things that the wise person does they
also act supportively meaning they're
very good companion at dinner parties
there's a whole list of things that they
do but he says though they're rotten
person have spoken up in two senses in
one sense with regard to virtue is a
type of worthwhile person in the other
regard device as a reproach is in the
case of person's math from the same
lesson valuable erotic love is for
friendship it produces friendship the
person worthy of erotic lobby says is
spoken of in the same way as a person
worthy friendship the desire to have
children we see is is there as well
Cicero speaking for K know you know very
Orthodox stoic it's consistent with
human nature for the wise person in
living by nature to take
spouse and to which they have children
now notice this next line not even
sexual passions a lot is that as pure is
considered to be incompatible with being
wise very interesting thing to say and
again sister was presenting the Orthodox
toy position at the time in saying that
when Sonia Rufus how many of you have
read with Sonia's Rufus's lectures too
many you want to read them they're very
interesting he was Epictetus teacher we
don't have too much of what he had to
say but he was very interesting figure
probably one of the most gender
egalitarianism
and for the Stoics they thought of this
in terms of marriage and we'll talk
about how we can not pass that include
more in just a moment so I said the
husband and wife should come together
for the purpose of making a life in
common and procreating children so so
far it sounds like the old line about
you know the purpose of marriage is
making babies you know perpetuating the
human race you get that sometimes from
people today right so there's only one
legitimate purpose by the way the range
of a Christian plot on this although
sometimes you get that as the Christian
line there's always been a number of
different ends for marriage recognized
very early on by my church fathers and
then through the middle ages there's a
great book called monks on marriage
that's well worth reading by Jonathan
clear on this very topic and those moms
were drawing on Cicero and Seneca to
think these things out so Sonia says
regard furthermore regarding all things
in common between them and nothing
peculiar a private to one or one or the
other not even their own bodies and now
notice the next thing in marriage there
must be above all love even making
babies perfect companionship and mutual
love of husband and wife well in health
and sickness
and under all conditions since it was
with desire for this as well as for
having children that both entered onto
marriage so again a very Orthodox and
consistent stomach showing us that the
ancient Stoics thought that the point of
coupling was not just you know making
babies you see actually says at one
point if you want to do that just one
prostitute
you know that's easy enough to do it's
to have intimacy or it's to have some
sort of common life together there are
other discussions that that talk even
and I didn't have them in here but that
talk even about the need for carrying
out financial decisions together some of
these fragments that we have Epictetus
I think illustrates another common stoic
attitude he was very very very I can't
give you enough berries against adultery
which was a common practice at that time
right it's probably this in common and
as it is today and he talks about the
person who commits adultery as
essentially robbing himself in this case
a guy who is also talented in other ways
and wanted to be regarded as a good
person because was talents robbing
himself of the the very person who he
was robbing himself of being the person
of fidelity business in the Greek
robbing himself of being a person of
justice and he essentially tells a guy
hey you're funny you're damaged goods
now you know nobody's gonna trust you on
anything and then there's this great
line in there that refers to this notion
of what they call that the time how does
it you put it the translation is uh yeah
are women not common by nature community
of women and children which is what
xenos Republic seem to be saying he says
sure yeah a little pig is common to all
the invited guests but when the portions
have been distributed go if you think
it's right snatch up the portion of the
person lying next to you and see
he likes it you know what about the
theaters of the theater Commonwealth
citizens yeah but when you put your butt
in that seat nobody else gets to sit
there and so epic Yunus is saying this
about you know sexual relations anybody
that have sex with anybody but once
you've formed that connection that's
that nobody else gets to intrude right
and if we want to think about how we
would apply this in our own lives today
we have to expand the scope considerably
right most people I think today don't
don't wait for marriage before having
some sort of sexual relationship many
people will never get married marriage
rates are declining I know they are in
the United States and even in marriages
that exist the divorce rate is extremely
high some people talk about serial
monogamy but what about the idea of a
committed partnership this is why we
chose to talk about Department relations
I think many people are still looking
for some sort of committed partnership
that they would have if not necessarily
over the course of their entire life
certainly for a long time and so I think
we have to think about that we also need
to think about sexuality and gender you
know the Stoics had traditional notions
about not just gender roles but about
homosexuality and LGBTQ things I think
there's no reason why we couldn't think
of what the Stoics are saying today as
applying to any sort of relationship
with people who are attracted to each
other in whatever way so long as nothing
stands in the way of virtue all right we
also need to think about something that
they didn't think about which is getting
into in seeking relationships you know
how would a stoic for example or would a
stoic use tinder or other might be
together no they wouldn't they wouldn't
use it for like hooking up but you know
people go on dates tender
I know it's used for many other things
as well but I think that's something you
would have to consider and there's other
challenges that arise as well and this
is where I was hoping handy would be
here we we have what you can call a
blended marriage she is a stepmother she
prefers the term bonus mom to my two
children and there's a lot of you know
interactions with people who already
have children from other marriages and
bring them together and it makes things
a bit more complicated right they often
say you know just marry the person you
marry a family in many cases that's
quite true
workplace relationships and other things
Stoics didn't talk that much about they
didn't know the modern workplace that is
where many many people find either their
dating pool or the person that they feel
themselves to be meant to be with and
then there's the demands of the work you
know we we Americans work more hours
probably than we should and I know that
happens quite a bit in Europe as well
depending on the country so that places
stresses on relationships and and raises
challenges and then the other thing that
I think the Stoics didn't talk that much
about is how partners would be support
in crisis I mean we see them modeling it
like Seneca Wright writing these letters
of consolation but if you have a
long-term relationship sooner or later
somebody's going to die and you need to
figure out how you're going to help that
person deal with the death of people
that they're close to I mean just as a
general point everybody in this room
either you're gonna die before me or
after me you know or at the same time
there's nobody around them you know so
either if we know each other either all
mourn you Morreale mourn me or maybe we
both go out together but that's
inevitable you cannot get away from that
so I think that's a big thing loss of
the job how do you help your partner
deal with this such a terrible economy
that
now how do you help your partners deal
with that sort of thing the Stoics don't
have that much to say directly about
that but I think we can adapt much of
what they do have to say to help us with
that so this is a great opportunity for
modern stoicism see how we are in time
so that's that's sort of enough about
the the stoic role let's talk about some
of these practices and perspectives so
the first woman that would be very
useful
I know we've used it a lot is dealing
with appearances and you heard some
discussion of that today appearances or
impressions are usually how it's
translated fantasy I they also mean
imaginations I was glad there was a talk
that made that connection
vasya is the Faculty of imagination
there are the things that they pinched
on us there are these immediate you
could say possibilities for judgment or
to suspend assent they're more than that
though we can recall them and bring them
to mind ourselves so appearances are
something that's that's extremely
important how far they extend if we look
at the makita's who is you know he's
presenting this as the stoic position
it's not just like external things that
we're seeing every movie you watch is a
system of appearances every book you
read is a system of appearances use the
Iliad as an example he says what is the
Iliad or what are these Greek tragedies
other than vast systems of appearances
you know what else is a system of
appearance firm for epictetus reason
itself you're very fat you're your
rational faculty the Logie cake do
demand which is by the way the same
thing is the ruling faculty and
another way is the same thing as the pro
races your Faculty of choice these are
all aspects of the same thing rather to
you know a whole conversation about them
they're all involving appearances you
never never get away from them there is
no inner Citadel to retreat to where it
would just be you and your judgments and
appearances would be on the outside even
those judgments are to some degree
appearance dependent so these are very
important and the idea in stoicism is
not to eliminate or just withdraw from
appearances it's to try to get them
right so what impact does this have on
our relationships a lot of what people
call communication problems from a stoic
perspective our appearance problems
their manners of us responding to what
it is the other person is saying or what
we think that what they're doing is
saying to us because everything a person
does can convey messages and rather than
following the advice of the Stoics which
is to test appearances to you know with
say wait a second I'm not sure if this
is what I'm perceiving it to be right
now we do what we react we infer we make
judgments about them and then we react
in certain way and then what happens you
know we do that on our own it's it's
problematic enough but when we're in a
dual relationship with a partner you can
set up the feedback loop right and so
how many of you have an experience of
being in a fight with your partner and
you say something and it's perfectly
reasonable in your eyes for you to say
this as a response to your partner to
the unreasonable thing that they say and
then they take what you said in the
worst way and argue with you that's
really you know of course
we do the same thing after they do it
that's arguing about appearances and you
can get very heated about that can't you
there's almost infinite capacity to
misinterpret what the other person is
saying especially if you choose to do
something like that so this is I think
the stoic techniques of withdrawing for
a moment and saying wait a second is
this really what's going on and then
bringing something to bear as we test
the appearances that can be
extraordinarily helpful in diffusing
things so you might think about it as
preventive maintenance that you need to
do within your relationship and the same
thing goes for when things are great you
know what's one of the common things
that happens to people when they first
start dating yeah now let's be what do
we mean by honeymoon phase where you
fall yeah
warning signs red flags yeah you know we
overlook so we have this appearance and
the appearances oh my god this person is
amazing we just can't stop talking about
them what if friends are like shut up
about so-and-so good posting things on
Facebook about how happy you are and you
are you know you are happy not in the
sense of you dialing yeah happiness but
you're happy joyful but it could be
based on all sorts of things that are
completely wrong and so we have to test
those appearances as well and this is
this might be the point where people are
like well screw it I don't want to be a
stoic
taking all the fun out of things right
we'll get to that in just a moment that
would be a legitimate worry I think what
else did I have here yeah we want to
avoid making inferences and I think we
should interpret the stoic insistence
that we bring to bear some sort of
criteria another one way to translate
condom and Greek some criteria we should
think about how do we fit these into a
larger picture that makes sense how we
construct a story in which both of us in
the relationship have some space to be
characters within the story that can be
quite helpful
the second thing I think you're probably
all familiar with the dichotomy of
control okay well some things are in our
control some things aren't we remember
their endocrine one what are the things
in our control money know what's it did
you see what's in our control judgments
yeah receptions are not in our control
we have them there might be a
translation that that's using it's a
little non-standard usually perceptions
would be fantastic choices those are in
our control desires and versions stoic
signals are actually in our control so
what if I have a compulsion well then
it's not so into your control you can't
turn it off it's certainly work at it
chipped away and that's when your
control opinions or judgments right
Doakes I what's not in your control
that's a big one that plays a huge role
in relationships what else
yeah your body we gonna have a whole
discussion you know I control whether I
brush my teeth or not or workout you
know whether I throw you know crap into
my body or eat healthy yes that's true
but you can still get walk out there and
get hit by the bus and it hits you hard
enough you're gonna die
that's nothing you can do about that
right you certainly can't do that what
else is not in that control history I
mean you don't even really control your
own history where you could have changed
things back then you're stuck with what
you can reinterpret yeah but I mean I I
can't not have grown up in Wisconsin you
know that's that's just the way it is
there's there's a whole bunch of choices
you know we can't choose the fact that I
have two children so the realm of what's
in our control that's often talked about
is something inner and then we have
these externals tacked on and those are
framed as being indifferent and I think
it's worth pausing for a moment just to
talk about what it means from a start
perspective or something to be
indifferent it doesn't mean that we're
indifferent to it usually one of the
reasons why we need stoicism is
precisely because of the fact that we
are not indifferent to things that want
to be indifference to us things that
don't make a difference with respect to
our moral goodness or badness or
happiness or our misery we find that we
actually do care about these things you
know I worry about money from
perspective that that's kind of
irrational but you can't change it
unless you recognize where you actually
are in terms of what is indifferent and
the Stoics thought that just because
something is strictly speaking and then
different doesn't mean that we should
say oh it doesn't you know do whatever
you want well they thought we should
manage or the word that they it's
usually translated use right crisis in
Greek we should use indifference
prudently or just the more courageously
and if we don't do that we're actually
doing something man we relax and devices
that way so think about the whole range
of things that are involved with a
typical date most of those are in
difference what you wear clothes so does
that mean that you should just like you
know throw on whatever and head out to
the date no you should you should wear
what you think is is actually going to
plant your good features one of the
examples of indifference by the way that
Cicero has Cato talk about good looks
right that's a preferred indifferent but
looks are something that you you know
you don't have a hell of a lot of
control over more more today and I think
in plastic surgery you know things like
that but you know you can work with what
you got right and the Stoics would say
if you're going out of date you probably
should work with what you got not to the
point where you're obsessing about it
but it is something that you know the
use of that and different is something
in your control how other people view
you that's a great right
Epictetus says that and Seneca says this
so often at times - anytime that you
desire somebody to respond in a certain
way you're making yourself a slave to
that person you are putting yourself
into their power you're actually that
mattias uses that very phrase you're
putting yourself something that you
actually do have control over into the
sphere of somebody else's control this
is a big problem in relationships and
you might say well
how can you manage this are you supposed
to just not care what the other person
thinks then you know how are you
connected with them how is that any sort
of intimacy you can practice the same
sort of thing as you do with everything
else like whether you're going to get a
job or not you know you're going to go
on a date is the date going to be a good
date or a bad day well you do the best
that you can but you don't control what
that other person is like maybe they're
a jerk you know maybe they're very
demanding maybe your interests are not
aligned enough for it to work we can say
the same thing about long-term
partnerships or marriages particularly
when people change over time you don't
control whether another person decides
to change a lot of times couples work on
each other and that's often quite
unsuccessful because it stems from a
desire to control the other person so
bringing them within the sphere of
control
that's a counterproductive strategy the
best you can do is simply to communicate
what you want to the other person and
then hope I said from story perspective
not strictly speaking hope but I have no
problem saying called hope that it's
going to turn out that way but be
prepared for the fact that it's not
going to if Andy were here she could
give you all sorts of anecdotes about me
and the things that she hoped I would do
differently and some of the realizations
she's had you know things that we buy I
am a clumsy guy I don't take care of
things very well and sooner or later one
of these cords is going to break because
I'm kind of rough with things like that
and I firstly really really bothered her
you know why because you know we're both
Midwesterners we both grew up in
households where we weren't ourselves
poor the poverty was always sort of at
the door and so you're frugal you know
you take care of things and I try my
best to take care of things but they
still bring you know that's because of
one dumb thing or
there and boy did that tick her off you
know why why is somebody who can like
pay attention to all these things when
it comes to writing an article
why can't you pay attention to not
breaking a dish well because that's
that's the best it's gonna be for me you
know sooner or later I'm going to break
a dish or a cup or a quart so you just
set aside a certain amount of money to
pay for that sort of thing that's the
rational thing to do you know Annie will
will oftentimes buy foodstuffs that you
know are gonna go into a great meal and
then time runs out and we have food
waste you know I still let myself get
really bent out of shape about that to
be very you know careful with this it's
it's bad to engage in food waste there's
hungry people in other places there's
going to be food waste you know so we
have to learn to use the dichotomy of
control and a very prudent way within
relationships a third one roles and
duties right again let's use that victi
does he says in the end karidian all of
our duties or another way of translating
this appropriate acts and things that we
ought to do our obligations are given to
us by our roles that we have so if I'm a
teacher there are certain things that I
should do in relation to my students
that maybe I don't have to do with the
average person on the street but because
of that relationship there are certain
requirements this is a big area of
contention isn't it great relationships
we often think that other people wasps
certain things because we're in a
relationship with them if you really
want to make things bad you know imply
that you know because you you deigned to
be in a relationship with them she
didn't have to do that they should do
something for you that's a great fight
smart
and why is it well because people don't
like feeling that way after hearing that
sort of thing it makes you feel like
you're not really about employment we
exist in a matrix of relationships right
and then we add to them romantic
relationships are ones that we choose to
get into I mean you can talk about
arranged marriages and those opposed
there are all sorts of issues but in
general who you date who you connect up
with long-term that's up to you if you
are in a relationship you know you may
feel like you don't have any say in it
anymore
but it is still up to you and so you
you've taken that on and so we can ask
what is the role of a partner we can ask
at different points to what you know if
you go on a date with somebody what even
is considered to be reasonable
expectations for me and showing up on
time you know or having a good reason
why you'd show up on time what else see
that's very important yeah hmm often
times you know you see that negatively
when people don't do that
you know that may be the end of the
debate mutual respect yeah that may be
the end of the date you know you're like
that's it that's a line I don't like
crossed what else how else should people
dating treat each other should they
should they act as if they are the most
important people in the world only only
they exist
this kind of very romantic image I only
see you I only think about you is that a
good thing or a bad thing what do you
think to be honest what's up
yeah well I mean what if you do feel
that way that should you lay that out
there you know when you come in the room
I don't see anybody else I think you
really do feel them and then you've got
to work with that right but you probably
shouldn't say that if that's how you
feel yeah authenticity another notion
that you know ancient stars didn't have
the vocabulary for what we do now
one of the things that we learn about
roles in a relationship there's by the
way very good book out there by Johnson
called the role the role and ethics of
that mckenas if you haven't read that
it's it's accessible it's worth worth
checking out one thing you would think
about is you know when he talks about
grasping things by the right handle know
that in that context the goal is a
property owner he says your brother is a
jerk to you how do you take it do you
pick it up find the handle my brother is
a complete you know a whole and I should
retaliate against him or something like
that if you pick it up by then handle he
says you're not going to be able to
endure it right but if you pick it up by
the handle that well he is my brother
and the universe doesn't owe me a good
brother just a brother and I choose what
I'm going to do with that brother he
says that is something that you can hear
it by can we apply that to relationships
dating marriage all those sorts of
romantic relationships I think the
answer is yes there will be many cases
where we have to apply that inevitably
if we spend enough time with the person
they are going to do things where if we
tally up the you know the benefits and
deficits on each side we're going to
take the wrong perspective and what we
have to do instead is say well this is
my life and you know the universe
doesn't
a wife who's perfect in every respect as
a matter of fact this thing over here is
quite galling but I choose what I'm
going to do in relation to her as a
husband if I if I make mine being if I
make mine fulfilling my role dependent
on her fulfilling her role or if she
does that with me neither of us are
going to do it for very long and this is
something that I think would fit into
the stoic notion of justice as well
because justice includes beneficence
doing good to other people it's not just
about following the rules
it's about benevolence so that's that's
important there is a concern that I
think it comes up in that case well what
do you do about somebody who's abusive
to you somebody who's manipulative
somebody who is disrespectful for
example over and over and over again and
I think this is a this is a real problem
the ancients know attacks especially
epic to unit sometimes give you the
impression that you could endure
anything whatsoever and that because you
could you should you know you want to
twist my leg well then you'll break it
and you know you're not going to break
me that sort of thing that sort of thing
is not really helpful for dealing with
say an abusive spouse because they'll do
that then those are more and more and
more so I think from here's were moving
them to bring in other resources right
we would have to think in terms of the
virtues particularly the virtues of
prudence or wisdom they have the virtue
of justice because you are somebody who
deserves him justice as well other
people owe you certain things and it's
not prudent to remain in a abusive
relationship I think from the
perspective of the present we have a
better vocabulary for making sense of
these things there is one thing though I
mention Cicero in on duties talks about
how courage when justice and temporary
I'm lacking quits be encouraged and we
can apply this directly to that
situation it's not courage to have
somebody beat you up physically or
emotionally or even financially over and
over and over again that's actually they
have it's not producing a better
situation just because you can endure
abuse so I think that's one of the
things we'd have to add to this roles
idea usually that's a pretty point
because usually assembly here you're
acting outside of a context right if
they're if abuse has taken place there's
already a context that is placed with a
one down position and then to say I'm
not going to allow this I'm gonna say go
to a shelter or something like that is a
scary step and so that would require
courage you know one of the other things
the Stoics don't talk about much they
think they could have talked about more
as sometimes we have to draw on the
virtues of others too
if I don't if I don't have enough
courage myself maybe I need to have my
friends join me up a vent you know or
somebody else who can give support
ideally that would be my romantic
partner but if my romantic partner is
the problem and usually abusive
relationships one of the things you see
is they isolate they cut you off from
all your sources of support and friends
and family emotions another big thing
stoicism is about having right kinds of
emotions a good talk this morning
you know highlighting the fact that
stoicism is not about being emotional as
there was a whole zest issue right very
interesting results that Tim found in
his research so for the Stoics this is
one of the things I really like about
stoicism they understand the cognitive
structure of emotions emotions are never
just feelings that we just have
they're not pure stimulus-response
either the way a lot of people would
like to see it emotions involved
judgments and we can unpack and examine
those judgments and figure out why we're
feeling the way that we're feeling what
it is that's going on with ourselves
the Stoics also offer us a you could say
interpretation of the emotions that
helps distinguish problematic emotions
and what's problematic about them from
positive emotions I don't entirely agree
with them myself neither for that matter
in Cicero it was an eclectic I think
maybe they go a little bit too far on
some issues or some emotions and
condemning them but Olympians for the
standard story take so there's certain
emotions that are by their very nature
excessive responses they're contrary to
reason they may in fact have some good
local facts but they're ultimately bad
for you so those would include things
like anger for example snowing seven
zero tolerance policy on anger which by
the way I don't follow but that's one of
the things that they think is always
uniformly problematic some other is that
we could probably agree on jealousy and
envy those are always going to be
problematic within relationships if
you're envious of your spouse it can
lead to a lot of issues excessive fear
or anxiety cripples many relationships
and actually prevents many relationships
another one of the source are considered
negative all news
Epictetus actually has an entire chapter
on it's translated on solitude but you
could translate it as on loneliness and
so you know we can look at each of these
and talk about how in specific cases
there are problematic responses but I
think what the real takeaway is stoicism
offers those resources for figuring out
what's going on why it's going on and
how to move away from it there are
positive
the stomach's think we ought to be
having the you paella right the three
big classes of these the Stoics
recognize our joy con research which is
a rational pleasure a pleasure
that is sort of aligned with our
rational faculty fully functioning
rational fear or caution you LA baya and
then rational desire or wish they also
talk a lot about love both in the sense
of you know friendship but affection and
also an erotic once we've seen to those
those are positive within certain you
might say strictures within certain
boundaries and here's where I think some
of you might again wonder once again
saying wow I want to be a stoic there I
want that feeling that I have when I'm
with my partner being like
head-over-heels in love and we should
think well is that you know do we want
them precisely because it's unreasonable
and irrational if we do then then you
can't then the stoic thing is not for
you right but you could ask yourself to
what degree could that be reasonable and
I would have to do with how it changes
your or fits in with your other
priorities would where I know we're
getting very short on time so I want to
jump right into the the next one virtues
and vices now then think about a mirror
image that your story is very important
illness we often talked in terms with
four cardinal virtues right wisdom
justice temperance courage that's great
that's a great starting point
the Stoics distinguished some virtues
under those all those things are very
useful and they help us if we use them
as criteria to evaluate ourselves and
our partners realistically in terms of
what we're getting wrong what we could
be doing better a good relationship is
going to require some measure
of those or at least not having the
places that are posed to them but one of
the things anything is left out in
ancient virtue ethics then some you know
modern version of the system of
attendant is precisely that dimension of
story the stories that we tell about
ourselves and the backstory that we have
that is just as much of a virtue or a
vice as is the habit of doing so virtues
and vices are also consolidated by
relationships if you want to make
progress don't think a bunch of dummies
to hang around this may mean this may
lead at some points of saying this
romantic partner is not for me if I want
to progress if I want to have a happy
life
you know somebody who's a drama queen or
king right who constantly needs to stir
things up that will not be compatible
with a stoic view on relationships
that's just not going to work and that's
wishful thinking - you know assume that
well if you just if you're stoic enough
you could actually make that work that's
not going to work you know also about
Socrates and Sam v Bay those aren't
really meant to tell us we should stay
in essentially abusive relationships or
unproductive relationships they're just
to say well Socrates could do that
because he was so purchase and case the
latest thing I'll say about this is that
virtue is really bear heavily on the
realm of indifference how we deal with
the things that are not in our control
how we use them you know and this would
include what other people think
including our romantic partner that is
very much within the scope of wisdom and
justice and courage and self-control or
temperance so in order to be a good
partner we're going to have to cultivate
the virtues can we expect our partner to
do so we don't have control right we
can't make you our husband or wife
become 10
or lies for them you know some some of
us are gonna keep making the same dumb
mistakes until we stop until we decide
it's a priority for us to stop making
those particular dumb mistakes so I
think these could be helpful the last
thing that I wanted to say is actually
not by a stoic but does have to do with
with virtue and how many of you read
about real case letters to a young poet
only it's you what were three very short
work Rainer Maria Rilke a great German
language existentialist pot right into
another diamond wants to be a comment
about whatever require real context
about things in fairly stoic ways he's
talked about solitude
I know sometimes in German which can
also be translated as loneliness and he
talks about the need to cultivate this
is sort of like the retreats of the
inner center though but it's not a
complete detachment from the world and
what he says is that a lot of people get
into relationships when they're not
fully developed and this is the case for
almost all of us at least with some
relationships we would have done better
to wait until we actually had everything
all figured out then start dating or
getting married but instead we jump in
at first and Rilke says well it's no
wonder they make a mess of it many
contrast' this is something else it's
something else
he says a real marriage would be one
where both people have developed
themselves fully and had this dimension
of solitude within themselves and he
talks about two solitudes protecting
each other that's his vision for the
ideal relationship which he appears to
enjoy this way at least in part from
what we can tell and I think that when
translate very well into a stoic
conception of virtue and vice as well as
the role protected the part of our
partners
but we haven't that means we have to
allow them room in which they can
cultivate themselves so I've thrown a
lot of stuff at you now that we have a
bit of time for Q&A and discussion and
I'll stay you know longer yeah Oh with
the Stoics in general yeah and even with
Cicero which is rare for me yeah so the
Stoics they have a zero tolerance policy
but it's always bad no productive uses
I'm more Aristotelian in that respect I
think that there are cases where anger
can in fact be useful but even Aristotle
says you got to be super super careful
with it sometimes the virtuous
disposition with respect to anger will
will be the person who is more forgiving
but he does think that we need it for us
sometimes and San Antonio goes after the
resilience
there's another thing to mention with
Cicero in Tusculum disputations Cicerone
kind of wavers back and forth the stoic
said there is no good version of pain or
sorrow and I think the Stoics are
probably wrong about that as well well
it's got to be in relation to reason
yeah time for the Starks lose yeah
sometimes you could faint and that's not
the same thing as showing anger which is
an action yeah right you said it can be
useful for the judge
anger because that criminal punishment
better behaved right we do this with
children too but you know the so much
work on the extreme when I came to that
Stoics and a few Christian thinkers in
ancient times the epicurean is the
Aristotelians the plaintiffs they were
all more towards those hopefully because
some some work relationships might be
very long lasting after you know as we
have a string of failed romantic
relationships I mean the Stoics have a
lot more to say about friendship than
they do about romantic relationships
valued it they don't talk much about
what we would call a modern workplace
relationships but there's no reason why
we can't extend the sort of things that
they're talking about into that
you know I mean the one thing is so when
in a romantic relationship you not only
are going to spend a lot of time with
that person the way you might say with a
business partner but you're spending
time with that person precisely because
you on some level want to be with them
where is the business partner you you
know you both lock the office up and
they go home so I think there is a
difference there and you might you know
you could say well I'm gonna Pelt this
new wonderful platform with this
business partner who's so brilliant
that's similar to like producing
children but it isn't it is you know
children are children I mean there are
you're bringing in actual people who are
totally unpredictable you can't you
can't really determine how it turned out
but you're you're responsible for them
so there I want to hold out that there's
something about romantic relationships
that is yeah so on that one I err on the
side of the assess myself personally
well you'd have to think because you
don't want to be you don't want to be
undemonstrative and so temperance does
bear the pleasures of it's called the
pleasures of the bed right as well as
drinking and eating and all these other
things laying around and the Sun part of
what it means to be temperate means to
you know remain within certain
boundaries so you know you could be very
demonstrative with the person that
you're in a relationship with and
have a high libido but also not look at
other people right you direct your
attention towards the one person because
you you want that to be an important
part of your your life together if you
wind up with somebody who's less
interests than than yourself then you
get a real quandary don't you
and then temperance might be saying well
and it won't be as often or as exuberant
as as I might like but this is going to
be off to adjust myself to this and and
not look for something else that would
be temperance I think but this is the
cool thing about romantic relationships
--is should be having sex it's possible
oh so when we think about virtues
virtues we think of them as habits and
they are happens but but a very
important dimension is also narrative
stories that we tell about ourselves
that fits into the habitus that is
virtually it as do the relationships
that we can I mean it's just something
that didn't come out of much yet and so
you can think about you know for example
trauma and when we make of trauma people
have bad childhoods and that affects how
they view not just sexuality
relationships in order to in order to
move towards virtue it's not like you
would leave the past behind but it might
require some reinterpretation of what
happened to honor the choices that one
may hurt being virtuous too is like
realizing wow I was really on virtuous
back there you know and I better not be
like that I don't think so I think that
the paradigm of the ancient paradigm of
some sort of fidelity is important now
could it could it be okay for like let's
do some reason I don't want a committed
relationship and I live in this
environment where it's very easy to hook
up with people we have apps that make
that easy there's less social opprobrium
attached to that should I should I enjoy
that sort of thing I mean you have to
ask well why is that
so central you know why is it a high
priority for you it'd be sort of like
saying well I want to have gourmet meals
every day you know why is it does that
fit in with the rest of the stoic life I
think the answer is no we don't know
what Xena said about them we don't have
seen those texts all we know is that he
was criticized for talking about certain
community of women and children sort of
like along the lines of Plato's Republic
and we'll call the Republic and then we
see how Athena sort of taking that up
and saying well sure that things are
common until we actually do make
decisions and then you better not take
somebody else's spouse right now they're
referring it solely in terms like men
being the ones to have the agency in
that case but we do
but at the point in time we don't know
what what xenon said most stoical
texture loss to us I would be great if
we found one that'd be cool all right
well thanks very much
you